قال رئيس الوزراء الفلسطيني محمد شيه في
موقف اعلنت فصائل فلسطينيه رفضه ان السلطه
الفلسطينيه سوف تستانف الاتصالات مع
اسرائيل في جميع المجالات واضاف ات ان
السلطه تسلمت رساله من اسرائيل تتعاهد
فيها بالالتزام بالاتفاقات الموقعه مع
[موسيقى]
الفلسطينيين
اهلا بكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ونناقش فيما
وراءه ما هي الاسباب الحقيقيه التي جعلت
السلطه الفلسطينيه ت تقرر استئناف
الاتصالات مع اسرائيل على جميع المستويات
سته اشهر بعد القطيعه بين الجانبين واي
انعكاسات لعوده الاتصال بين السلطه
واسرائيل على الموقف والمشهد الفلسطيني
الذي شهد في الاونه الاخيره لقاءات بين
الفصائل الفلسطينيه لتنسيق الموقف
[موسيقى]
بينها لم تصمد القطيعه بين السلطه
الفلسطينيه واسرائيل سوى سته اشهر وها هي
حبال الاتصالات تعود لتمتد بين الجانبين
وعلى اكثر من صعيد وزير الخارجيه
الاسرائيلي جابي اشكنازي رحب بعوده
التنسيق الامني بين السلطه الفلسطينيه
واسرائيل وخلال مؤتمر صحفي مشترك مع نظيره
البحريني في القدس المحت
دعا اشكناز الفلسطينيين الى العوده
للمفاوضات مع اسرائيل دون
شروط نرحب باستئناف التعاون والتنسيق
الامني بين السلطه الفلسطينيه واسرائيل
وانا ادعو الفلسطينيين الى العوده الى
المفاوضات دون شروط مسبقه لقد اتفقنا خلال
محادثاتنا على فتح سفاره اسرائيليه في
المنامه وفتح سفاره للبحرين في اسرائيل
وسنقيم مراسم رسميه لتخليد هذا هذه اللحظه
التاريخيه حركه حماس كواحده من الفصائل
الفلسطينيه التي استنكرت الخطوه دانت من
جانبها وبشده قرار السلطه الفلسطينيه
استئناف العلاقات مع اسرائيل حماس اكدت ان
القرار يمثل طعنه للجهود الوطنيه لمواجهه
الاحتلال والضم والتطبيع وخطه السلام
الامريكيه تستنكر حركه حماس قرار السلطه
الفلسطينيه في رام الله باعاده العمل
بالاتفاقات مع الاحتلال واعاده التنسيق
الامني مع الجيش الصهيوني هناك هذا القرار
خطيئه سياسيه كبيره ترتكبها السلطه
الفلسطينيه في هذا الوقت الذي يشتد فيه
مسار التطبيع وهناك هجمه استيطان كبيره
على السلطه ان تتراجع فورا عن هذا القرار
وتعتذر للكل الوطني عن هذه الطعنه لجهود
اعاده ترتيب البيت الفلسطيني وطعنه لجهود
الوسطاء الذين تحركوا من اجل بناء هذا
المسار على السلطه ان تعود الى حاله
الاجماع الوطني الرافع لمثل هذه الاتفاقات
والتي تتبنى خيار المقاومه الشعبيه
[موسيقى]
الشامله
نناقش هذه الخطوه من قبل السلطه
الفلسطينيه مع ضيوفنا من نابلس المحلل
السياسي الدكتور عبد الستار قاسم ومن
القدس الكاتب والمحلل السياسي مائير كوهي
ومن رام الله موفق مطر عضو المجلس الوطني
الفلسطيني والقيادي في حركه فتح اهلا
بضيوفي وابدا بضيفي من رام الله موفق مطر
لاساله عن هذه الخطوه التي وصفت
بالمفاجئات ل طالما كان عندما اعلن الرئيس
ابو مازن والقياده الفلسطينيه عن تجميد
العلاقه وايقاف العلاقه مع ال حكومه
الاحتلال كان بسبب
ان صفقه
القر
قد
ربما مضى فيها دونالد ترامب الرئيس
الامريكي وان اعلان
نتنياهو حكومه دوله الاحتلال منظومه
الاحتلال فيضم اراضي الاغوار وكذلك في
مناطق عديده
فييه الى وفرض قياده القانون الاحتلالي
الاسرائيلي عليها كان هذا هو مبرر ال
قطع العلاقات وكما قال الرئيس انه من
اليوم في ذلك الحين نحن في حل من هذه
الاتفاقيات مع الحكومين الامريكيه وكذلك
الاسرائيل الان هنالك امور قد تغيرت في
الواقع على اولا لا الضم حصل وهذا بسبب
صمود الشعب الفلسطيني ومقاومته لخطه الضم
ولا ايضا سو القرن قد مضت وايضا
استطاعت المضي وتنفيذ بنودها على الارض
هنا في بسبب ايضا ان القياده الفلسطينيه
الرئيس ابو مازن بشجاعته وصلابته عبر عن
الموقف الشعبي الفلسطيني بكل ما يمكن وقال
لا كثيره لدونالد ترامب فيما لم يستطع احد
في هذا العالم ان يقول له لا وبالتالي هذه
المتغيرات اضف الى ان هذا الحصار السياسي
وال المالي والاقتصادي
وجائحة
العلاقه مع الاحت وتجميدها هنالك ايضا
شجاعه وحكمه في ارجاعها طالما ان هنالك
تعهد كما قال رئيس مجلس الوزراء وكما قال
ايضا وزير الشؤون المدنيه اح الشيخ امس
وبالتالي هذا التعهد اذا هناك شيء تحقق
مثل ما فهمتوا من كلامك السيد مطر على
الصعيد السياسي وهنا اسال ضيفي من القدس
السيد مائير كو
هل حققت السلطه
الفلسطينيه ايا من النقاط التي لاجلها
قامت بخطوه المقاطعه
السابقه ما في شك ان هذه الخطوه تصب في
مصلحه السلطه الفلسطينيه بالدرجه الاولى
ولذلك للاعتبارات التاليه اولا السلطه في
حاله انهيار وعلى وشك
الانهيار الوضع الاقتصادي وال المتفاقم
انتشار و الكورونا بالاضافه الى ذلك
الصراع على السلطه لخلافه ابو مازن ا اضيف
الى ذلك طبعا فقدان السلطه الفلسطينيه
للدعم العربي بل حتى ايضا دعم الاتحاد
الاوروبي حتى بقرض مالي وهذا يعود لان ابو
مازن تخلى عن اتفاق اسلو عندما قال ان
السلطه الفلسطينيه في حل عن عن الاتفاقات
الموقعه مع اسرائيل وبالتالي هو لم يحصل
على سيد
ماير خطه الضم الاعتقاد هي انها معلقه
وانها يعني حتى الان ليست موضوعه على على
الطاوله ا وهذا يعود لسبب اولا ترامب هو
لم يتخلى عن خطه الضم بالنسبه لاسرائيل
وفي عرضه ولكن
الذي لم يتمكن من تحقيق ذلك هو نتنياهو
لانه مقابل ذلك ترامب قال له عليك
الاعتراف بحل الدولتين وهو في هذه الحاله
لم يستطع ان يعني يقدم هذه المبادره
لليمين الاسرائيلي التي كان من المتوقع ان
يرفضها وبالتالي خطه الضم الضم
علقت فيما يتعلق ابقى معك سيد مائير معنى
ذلك ان القرار المعلن منذ البدايه فيما
يتعلق بخطه الضم لم يتغير فيه اي شيء
بالتزامن مع هذا القرار من قبل السلطه
الفلسطينيه
باعاده الاتفاقات او اعاده التنسيق مع
الجانب الاسرائيلي مع ان لي لا شيء يتغير
ايه الواضح هو انه لم يتغير والقرار هو
فقط معلق
وهناك يعني حاله ترقب للشهرين القادمين
اسرائيل بتحاول بقدر الامكان الحصول على
نوع من الانجازات خلال فتره عهد ترامب
قبيل تسلم بايدن السلطه ا وهذا بيسبب حاله
من التوجس في ال في الجانب الفلسطيني رغم
طبعا التوقعات بامكانيه حدوث حاله من
التغيير كنت ساذهب لضيف في نابلس الاستاذ
عبد الستار قاسم ولكن هناك قلل فني فقط
سوف نحاول ان نصلحه فيما يتعلق بالصوت
بيننا وبين ضيفنا الدكتور عبد الستار قاسم
لذلك اعود الى ضيفي من رام الله موفق مطر
فيما يتعلق
ب حتى صحف اسرائيليه علقت على خطوه
الفلسطينيه بانها عباره عن ف ف شل في
تسيير المرحله الماضيه وبالتالي وجدت
السلطه الفلسطينيه نفسها ملزمه على ان
تعود على القرار السابق وبالتالي تتخذ هذا
القرار باعاده التنسيق مع الجانب
الاسرائيلي ما
تعليقك عندما تتعهد الحكومه الاسرائيليه
باعاده الوضع الى ما كان عليه قبل 19 خ
هذا يعني
انهيا الفلسطينيه ان تعود ايضا الى هذا ما
كان وض
عليه بمعنى ان خطه الضم سواء الغيت من اج
سواء علقت الان اذا اعادها الى الواجهه
بالتاكيد سيكون هنالك
القرار المناسب من القياده
الفلسطينيه نحن نعيش في عالم متغير ف
نراقب كل حركه في هذا العالم سواء التي
معنا وسواء التي
ضدنا الخطه الاستعماريه التي طرحها دونالد
ترامب تحت عنوان صف القرن ندرك مخاطرها
وندرك انها ما زالت ربما هنالك البعض
ينفذها سواء على ربما بمهمات يؤديها بعض
النظام الرسمي العربي مثل التطبيع
الاماراتي والبحرين وغير ذلك وهنالك ايضا
مهمات تقوم بها منظومه حكومه الاحتلال
وبالتالي ندرك ايضا ان خطه الضم هي جزء لا
يتجد وحرفيا جاءت في خطه ترامب ولكن موضوع
حل الدولتين اذا كان هنالك كمتغير تستطيع
القياده الفلسطينيه التعامل معه بواقعيه
وعقلانيه وحكمه وصلابه وتمسك بالثوابت
فلما لا لا ننسى ان مجلس الامن قبل ايام
كان قد اثنى على مبادره الرئيس ابو مازن
في موضوع رؤيته لحل الدولتين وبالتالي
هنالك ايضا اجتماعات قادمه لمجلس الامن
سيناقش فيها بالتفصيل هذه الرؤيه حيث دع
الرئيس ابو مازن الى عقد مؤتمر دولي مع
بدايه العام ل
مناقشه حل الدولتين او بالاح طيب فقط
اعذرني الان اصبح ضيفنا من من نابلس
الدكتور عبد الستار جاهز لاساله فيما
يتعلق
ب توقيت الاعلان او القيام بهذه الخطوه هل
فيه ما يمكن من تفسير هذه الخطوه التي
وصفت بانها خطوه مفاجئه
للجميع اخونا عبد القادر بدايه ملاحظه
يعني ارجو في المرات القادمه ان تقولوا
لنا من سيشارك لانني شخصيا لا ارغب في
الظهور مع اسرائيليين هذا من حقك هذا يعني
ضرب من ضروب التطبيع ونحن نرفضه على ا حل
لماذا
الان هناك متغيرات على راسها المصالحه ما
بين حركتي فتح وحماس وايضا الانتخابات
الامريكيه يعني في هناك تقدم وتطور كبير
جدا في المحادثات والحوارات بين فتح وحماس
وهذا كان يؤذن بنوع من التفاؤل على الساحه
الفلسطينيه كما ان اجتماع الامناء العامين
للفصائل قد بشر ببعض الخير على الرغم من
اننا لم لم نرى نتائجه لكن بشر ببعض الخير
انه يمكن ان نحقق وحده وطنيه فلسطينيه
وهناك في الداخل الفلسطيني وفي الخارج
الفلسطيني من يريد ان يعرقل مثل هذا الوضع
لان قوه الشعب الفلسطيني تكمن في وحدته
فهناك من من دائما يصر على اضعاف الشعب
الفلسطيني بقدر الامكان ومن الناحيه
الثانيه الانتخابات الامريكيه هناك في
السلطه الفلسطينيه
منهم بان الامريكيه الجديده ستختلف عن
ممارسات الرئاسات الامريكيه السابقه ولكن
في هذه الحاله
ووع من الم لما لم يتم
حت الابيض ثم يتم القيام بهذه الخطوه فقط
انا اسال لفهم التوقيت الان
لماذا سؤالي استاذ عبد لك لك دكتور ع لك
دكتور عبد
الستار اه نعم اه ف شوف يعني اولا نحن كنا
ننتظر هذه الخطوه من السلطه الفلسطينيه
لانه كان عندنا قناعه انها لن تصمد و
وبالتالي هي ستضع تضرج يعني رويدا رويدا
نحو اعاده العلاقات والدليل على ذلك ان
السلطه الفلسطينيه لم تلغي العلاقات مع
الكيان الصهيوني وانما جمدت العلاقات
والتجميد معناه انه غدا سيتحول الى الحاله
المائيه ومن ثم الى الحاله البخاريه او
الغازيه الشيء الثاني انه على مدى الاشهر
السابقه لم تقم السلطه باي او لم تقدم اي
خطه او مشروع او استراتيجيه للشعب
الفلسطيني لتبنيها من حيث ان من المفروض
اننا دخلنا مرحله جديده مرحله تطبيق
اتفاقيات اوسلو تختلف عن مرحله العزوف عن
اتفاقيات اوسلو لكنها لم تفعل شيئا بمعنى
انها جمدت الاوضاع الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
والاخلاقيه والثقافيه في الساحه
الفلسطينيه انتظارا لقرار كنا نتوقعه وهذا
ما حصل لكن اخونا عبد القادر انه هناك
في تداعيات كبيره لمثل هذا القرار وانا
اذكر منها
اولا هناك ضرب لفكره الوحده الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه يعني الفصائل الفلسطينيه هل
تقبل بمثل هذا القرار بعد اجتماع الامف
نتناول هذا المحور ع س نتناول هذا المحور
الجزء الثاني من هذه الحلقه والذي يعنى
بانعكاسات هذه الخطوه على الداخل
الفلسطيني او على صعيد العلاقه الفلسطينيه
الاسرائليه و اسال ضيفي من القدس السيد
مائير كوهين بالدخول في هذه النقطه قلت
قبل قليل بان هذه الخطوه في مصلحه الجانب
الفلسطيني او السلطه الفلسطينيه كيف
والحكومه الاسرائيليه نفذت كل شيء سياسه
الاستيطان ما زالت متواصله سياسه الضم
بشكل او باخر ايضا تتم وكل ما هددت به
السلطه او الجانب الاسرائيلي تقوم به
الحكومه الاسرائيليه وبالتالي اين مصلحه
الجانب الفلسطيني في عوده التنسيق الامني
وباقي الخطوات
الاقتصاديه نعم وحتى في حاله وقف التنسيق
الامني مع اسرائيل والقرار الذي اتخذ قبل
سته اشهر فان التنسيق على الاعلى مستوى
كان يتم اولا من حيث التعاون في المجال
الامني
والاستخباراتي بالاضافه الى ان هناك يعني
عشرات الالاف من العمال كانوا يت يتفاوضون
يتوافدون اسف من من المناطق الفلسطينيه في
السلطه الفلسطينيه الى العمل داخل اسرائيل
و وبذلك الحاله لم تتوقف هناك يعني كل ما
يدعون بان اسرائيل ويعني هناك تعاون وهناك
تنسيق و وهذه الاتفاقيه هي جزء من اتفاق
اسو وبالتالي لا يمكن التخلي عن هذه
الاتفاقيه سواء من جانب اسرائيل او حتى من
جانب الفلسطينيين الى درجه ان الفلسطينيين
طلبوا يعني التزام اسرائيلي بالمحافظه على
بالالتزام بالف اسلو وحصلوا عليه منسق
شؤون الاعمال اعمال المناطق في في اسرائيل
وهو طبعا بتفويض من الحكومه الاسرائيليه
يعني بعنى اسرائيل ملتزمه باتفاق اسلو فكل
كل من يحاول ان هو يتملص لسبب او لاخر
الواقع هو ان الحياه يجب ان تستمر هناك
معوقات السلطه الفلسطينيه على وشك النيار
هناك رفض عربي لكل ما يتقدم به الجانب
الفلسطيني بعد الهجوم الشنيع الذي قاموا
به ضد الاتفاقات السلام مع اسرائيل اضافه
اضافه لذلك الى الى اوروبا نضيف الى هناك
عامل اخر ربما ابو مازن يريد ايضا اعطاء
يعني رساله موجهه الى رئيس المنتخب الجديد
بايدن باتخاذ هذه الخطوه
وكبد لحسن النيه تجاه الاداره الامريكيه
طيب اللافت اللافت في كلامك الان سيد
مائير هو الاشاره الى ما ذكرته الان اسال
عنه ضيفي السيد موفق مطر هناك هجوم كما
يقول ضيفي السيد مائير كوهين هجوم عربي
على الجانب الفلسطيني لتمل من الاتفاقات
قبل قليل سيد مطر قلت بان ايضا موجه
التطبيع العربي بشكل او باخر كانت من ضمن
الاسباب التي دفعت بالجانب الفلسطيني الى
القيام بهذه الخطوه الان وزير الخارجي
البحريني موجود والتقى مع الجانب
الاسرائيلي وهذه الخطوه قرئت من قبل
الفصائل فلسطينيه واطراف اخرى بانها ايضا
انما هي تكريس وموافقه على هذه او حاله
التطبيع العربي ومباركه لها وليس
العكس استطيع ان اؤكد لك بان بانه لا يضغط
على الرئيس ابو مازم وعلى القياده
الفلسطينيه واقول بالتحديد الرئيس لا يضغط
عليه الا المصلحه الوطنيه العليا للشعب
الفلسطيني المصالح الوطنيه العليا اولا لا
التطبيع ممكن ان يضغط عليه ليغير قرار ولا
حتى ولا حتى بالنسبه للوحده الوطنيه
الوحده الوطنيه بالنسبه لنا كمناضل وطنيين
في حركه التحرر الوطنيه الفلسطينيه
وبالنسبه للرئيس ابو مازن هي عقيده عقيده
سياسيه موازيه للعقيده اليه وبالتالي
بالتالي لا علاقه لجهود المصالحه وكل
اجتماع امناء الفصائل ومخرجاته والقرارات
التي خرج بها بموضوع اعاده العلاقات مع من
يريد الوحده الوطنيه الحقيقيه من يريد
مواجهه الاحتلال عليه ان يبقى مستن في هذا
الاتجاه ل مسانده القياده الفلسطينيه ولكن
هذه الفصائل سيد موفق وصفت هذه الخطوه
بانها طعنه في الظهر وتنصل من مسار للوصول
الى اتفاق الى وحده
فلسطينيه لا لا ابدا ابدا لا يمكن القول
في هذا لماذا لان الفصائل التي تعترض
اليوم على هذا القرار كانت قد قد وقعت
عديد المرات على اتفاقات اثنين منهم
بالقاهره واحد بعام 2011 وواحد 2014 وواحد
في الدوحه وكفي واحد في غزه في حمام الشط
الكثير من الاتفاقات كانت وقعت عليها
وتماطل ونستطيع ان نقول انها ماطلت كثيرا
وكانت قد وعدت بعد
اجتماعات فتح وحماس في اسطنبول في مقر
القنصليه الفلسطينيه بانهم سيكتبون ردا
مكتوبا وحسب ما طلب منهم الرئيس ابو مازر
ردا مكتوبا حركه فتح قدمت حركه اللجنه
المركزيه قدمت لحماس رؤيه مكتوبه وكان يجب
ان تقدم حماس هذه الرؤيه رؤيتها المكتوبه
ايضا لمركزي فتح وللرئيس لكنها لم تفعل
طيب اذا كنت قد فهمتك بشكل جيد سيد موفق
اذا في في مقاربتك هناك مساران مسار
خطوه اعاده العلاقات مع الجانب الاسرائيلي
لكنها لن تؤثر على المسار الاخر المتعلق
بالحوار الفلسطيني الفلسطيني وهنا اسال
ضيفي الدكتور عبد الستار قاسم بكل واقعيه
هل لدى السلطه الفلسطينيه والرئيس محمود
عباس بدائل اخرى في ظل الوضع الاقتصادي
الحالي في ظل كورونا في ظل ما ذكره ضيفي
قبل قليل من القدس مواقف عربيه من تطبيع
ومنع للمساعدات الماليه مواقف اوروبيه
ماذا يستطيع الان مثلا الموظفون في السلطه
الفلسطينيه الى الان يستلمون نصف الراتب
او لا يستلمون من باب الواقعيه هل لدى
الرئيس الفلسطيني اي بدائل اخرى حتى لا
يقوم بهذه الخطوه ويستمر في القرار
السابق ماو يا اخي الكريم يعني في هناك
مشكله كبيره ان تلقي بالشعب في الصحراء
بدون خطط وبدون استراتيجيات وبدون بنى
تحتيه وبدون مشاريع اقتصاديه والى اخره
ومن بعد ذلك تقول ما هو نحن في ورطه شو
بدنا نعمل بدنا نرتمي باحضان العدو هذه
جدليه مرفوضه
نهائيا الشعوب الحيه هي التي تعتمد على
انفسها ولا تعتمد على عدوها في
لقمه للاسف مازال هناك خلل في الاتصال
بيننا وبين ضيفنا من نابلس الدكتور دتور
عبد الستار قاسم لاذهب الى ضيفي من القدس
مائير كوهين
ا سيد
ماير ايضا فيما يتعلق بانعكاسات هذه
الخطوه في هذا التنسيق وعوده التنسيق
الاقتصادي وكذلك الامني مع الجانب
الاسرائيلي فيما تقوم به الحكومه
الاسرائيليه من خطوات تعتبرها السلطه
الفلسطينيه هي تقويض لحل الدولتين في ظل
اداره امريكيه جديده ربما تحمل مقاربه
مختلفه سيد مائير نعم ما في شك ان الانظار
تتجه نحو سنه 20 21 مع استلام الرئيس
بايدن المنتخب مهام منصبه ربما ستكون هناك
رؤيه
مختلفه تتعلق بعمليه السلام ولكن انا لا
اعتقد ان او المراقبين لا يعتقدون ان
الاداره الامريكيه الجديده ستسارع في دفع
للوصول الى تسويه لانها هذه الاداره جربت
في عهد اوباما فشل المحادثات مع الجانب
الفلسطيني عندما كان جون كيري وزيرا
للخارجيه وبالتالي من الاعتقاد هو ان
المبادره الامريكيه ستكون نحو تجاه
الفلسطينيين هي اعاده ضخ الاموال التي
قطعت في عهد ترامب فتح مكتب
المنظمه وربما تغيير السفير الامريكي طبعا
في في اسرائيل بسفير
اخر وكل هذه الامور لكن ليس من المتوقع ان
تكون هناك صراع في عمليه التسويه لان
المشاكل الداخليه في الولايات المتحده هي
في صلب الاهتمام معي الا دقيقه واحده
اقسمها بين ضيفي اعود الى الدكتور عبد
الطار لان اتصال بيننا بينه قد انقطع
ليكمل فكرته ثم اذهب الى ضيفي في رم الله
دكتور عبد
الستار نعم نعم اه ف قلت يعني انه المفروض
انه كان في سياسات فلسطينيه عبر 27 ماضيه
من اتفاق اوسلو بحيث ان نخرج من الاعتماد
على الكيان الصهيوني يعني في عننا تجارب
عالميه كثيره مثل كوبا مثل كوريا الشماليه
مثل ايران مثل قطاع غزه الى اخره نستفيد
من هذه التجارب من اجل ان نرفع من مستوى
الاعتماد على انفسنا بقدر الامكان لكن
للاسف الشديد هذه قياده فلسطينيه فاشله في
كل مجالات الحياه وتركتنا في العراء لكي
ينهش الاعداء اها اما ما هذا ما حصل حصل
لم يبقى معي الا
بضق جدا على السح تقييم هذا الوضع في ظل
هذا الجدل وهذه الخطوه الجديده باختصار لو
تكرمت يعني ما بعرف يا دكتور عبد الستار
قاسم طبعا هذا هو موقفه دائما لا يعجب
العجب ولا صيام في رجب كما بقولوا بالمثل
الشعبي الموضوع هو الان نحن على الاقل على
الاقل سته شهور وحتى سنه ماضيه كان كان
كان الموظف الفلسطيني يعيش بنصف راتب
مقدرات الاقتصاد الفلسطيني نعم
صعبت اصبحت دون المستوى
ولكن نحن دائما كنا نقول نحن لا يمكن ان
نفاضل ولا
نبدل ال هذا ما يجب ان
يفه من رام الله موفق مطر عضو المجلس
الوطني الفلسطيني وكذلك ضيفي من نابلس
المحلل السياسي الدكتور عبد ال قاسم وكذلك
لضيف من القدس مائير كوهين المحلل والكاتب
السياسي اذا نصل الى ختام هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في
قراءه جديده في ما وراء خبر جديد الى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء